yeah
you
it's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey here June Friday the 17th one
of your life no parole
it's been a long [ __ ] week but guess
what [ __ ] it's over you understand me
I got some tremendous weeds here and
this Paris oh gee you know what this is
my demo label Soledad
it's called dad this [ __ ] here I'm just
gonna squish this anthem explain to you
I bought this weed last night
okay it's a hundred [ __ ] for here
today I put in a brown bag I left in the
car all [ __ ] day jiu-jitsu every time
left with a [ __ ] car I just went down
there now to get it's nice and [ __ ]
Drive this is the weed of debt I don't
like my weed wet man so I can just put
in the bowl let's it's over too far away
from you [ __ ] you know Sam I'm
just wishing this up getting this ready
and be well off the [ __ ] French
boogers yeah yeah I was willing a
[ __ ] stole was lesson either [ __ ]
stoned to them we we have a [ __ ]
friend's mom in Starbucks herself Tara
let's smoke a joint ain't wings get the
[ __ ] out of here Uncle Joe is showing up
with the [ __ ] tooth tongue Toni
Collette don't weed is the we Jung Gotti
smoke before we [ __ ] shot Paul
Castellano
look at that tremendous aspera solji my
iron weeds when I want to see the
[ __ ] devil I'm gonna [ __ ] perennial
right you should see the [ __ ] devil
do what I want see [ __ ] the devil but
in a different status now he said a
different stratosphere I go to [ __ ]
herbal over here and I get the stars I
get the whole thing Lee's coming over
later but doing it all this weed is good
nice you know sometimes you get wait to
talking a bit conversation it just hits
you you're like oh [ __ ] we're gonna go
deep with this week try longer to [ __ ]
your plans up but I know what my plans
are
we're gonna [ __ ] heavy-duty I had a
couple Starling like ten thousand
milligrams a snozzberry wait
what happened to my [ __ ] poker
somebody stole my book I think those
[ __ ] in three Mormon chief came back
and I got a q-tip not wearing a mais on
those [ __ ] they came up here they
stopped my pipe asked me for water him
water this still my black me and Magnum
[ __ ] ball man grunts both of them
cockeyed two out of three will [ __ ]
[ __ ] tiny little handbasket [ __ ] up
shoes
I know what the time was now wanna smoke
the black container master one
make a salad no we [ __ ] thrive little
I like the ski it's got the last two
days I'm just smoking gusty understand
you like joy well you like that way me
and my friends mean we smoke it man it
so I don't give a [ __ ] me you and your
[ __ ] creepy friends do right tell you
what up the [ __ ] dog Joey desert
[ __ ] with style you got maybe an effort
Billy what bad [ __ ] flavors style
yeah I'm saying I don't see nobody else
burning up a peel they [ __ ] flavor
this you know why cuz I'm young I don't
just [ __ ] dog [ __ ] I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna [ __ ] do it concept
understand I got my doubts about myself
and I invite you [ __ ] as I am
expecting you to be savage you see
because I smoked and dope throwing
people out windows that type of [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] Friday [ __ ]
if you're gonna come in with your Pepe
LePew hat and some story about your
friends and we're gonna club join the
night get the [ __ ] out of here you know
I'm doing I'm come on a club PA seated
me
little boy flaps
see my member traicee throw it down
maybe slip a [ __ ] star at nothing this
[ __ ] Heineken to some [ __ ]
he'll have his shirt off his underwears
off he's over there Burbank Mickey Mouse
with me but bugger the [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] line coming around like a [ __ ]
like that if you ain't doing it like
that I don't know what the title you
probably added a bar jumping up and down
it's a happy hour look at us get the
[ __ ] man you look at me [ __ ]
right here on the balcony madam our
business ain't will be bottom the
business world closed share me from time
to time [ __ ] and [ __ ] new business from
Susan's walking the dog yet it is the
moment never ends
like that that's it you worked hard you
played on the eyeballs it was a rough
week
Orlando alligators taking kid yeah it's
just a fucked-up they call this [ __ ] go
Cindy come kitty imagine Grace Tanya
your logic is tired from hearing this
[ __ ] you know they went to his house two
times and the rest is [ __ ] anyone hit
don't matter it's Friday it's Miller
time
it's TAC time Uncle Joe okay all I can
tell you is who had a good week together
we're back [ __ ] Monday Wednesday
Philly I see you next week it's sold out
already don't even think about it and I
said you bad [ __ ] you know I
will show that you know all the things
that happened visit you you
[ __ ] a salad like the rocket
Gibraltar tanks out
hope will join one of those
[ __ ] that's gonna tell you a
long story without [ __ ] Walmart for
you you'll get those people to come to
the house if they lost a nipple did the
joints burn it but you want to tell me
about your [ __ ] aunt and I'll roll
the skates I don't give a [ __ ]
we give a [ __ ] about one thing again
doing it right no more balls what the
[ __ ] it's from hey eight don't say I
know listen there ain't no real battle
take me I'm the real deal this is my man
Timmy
Julian New Jersey and co-op is running
things over there it's Friday night he's
out chocolate and up and down he thinks
it's on 64th field circa 1980 [ __ ]
one those days a long time constant I
think I'm all mine in my business these
people so I can't put the lid of this
day I can't put the lid on the [ __ ]
job
thousand [ __ ] times I can't become a
knowledge right now a Rubik's Cube would
wait
we are don't report it now I got a
[ __ ] servant move it
oh yeah look at that who blows clouds
and you like that uncle [ __ ] and Joey
can't suck this natural you know why
because I love you [ __ ]
look at that bugle I got for [ __ ]
knows I gotta do something anyway I love
you people have a great weekend don't
forget about me
he's safe you know uncle Joey loves you
keep your eyes on you see something
suspicious
boy oh boy if only over deep ways it
would bother me that means put the eye
on that [ __ ] I'm sayin how're
you gonna do it I love you guys from the
bottom of my heart till I am doing the
no silly I'm off August Oklahoma Denver
Nashville are you [ __ ] kidding me
September we are Austin we have [ __ ]
New York City October Columbus we smooth
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out dawg
that's my lady anyway let me start up
singing [ __ ] songs November where my
aunt and [ __ ] Boston at the will
birthday the December map informant with
those blue truth and I said but you know
what all I'm worried about is tomorrow
at the submission gym with my main man
Tommy Easter and my main man Willie
Barcena get up he's trying to put the
pieces together before this
especially I wanna give you the best
Pesci [ __ ] dissing me I'm a
[ __ ] survival hey I love you guys
stay black
Joey beep oh yeah well I'm with the a
torn-up are sorry to uh sorry I am
stay black